but at 16 you're allowed to leave school
yeah you are and I did you get out of
school you figure hey maybe I'll be an
electrician you try that and then the
punk scene happens punk rock that was
liberating yeah and you were like well I
can [__] do this yeah all of a you
never took music lessons right you were
not a musician no and you decide well
I'll play drums in a punk band yeah now
now can it really be that simple my
older brother had had a drum kit that he
didn't use and it was it was lying
around you know in this kind of garage
thing that was next to the house so I'd
go in and play it and because I had a
drum kit that was enough like when punk
started people forget this now but
everybody was in a band right everybody
was in a band you have the whole look oh
yeah yeah I well what I used to do was
like I had to wear my school uniform to
go to school or so I'd take that and
then I'd go out at night and then there
was a bridge near my house and I would
dress you know put on a trash bag and
safety pins and hide my clothes under
the bridge